hello and welcome to another fun night
of chess and psychology well that's just
the title of the class so
don't hope for me sitting up here and
explaining psychology and i will embed
psychology in the moves that we think
but this is not a psychology class by no
means without the university course that
i am actually taking right now
normal psychology we'll talk about that
later
today i'm very excited because last week
finally guess what arrived
my baby my beautiful beautiful baby
finally arrived
and there were t-shirts there were mugs
i was hoping i was holding the mug right
now actually i did not plan that could
have done better wait mugs plural yeah
there are two sorry
there are a few t-shirts there is my
beautiful beautiful fur baby back here
my my handsome and very talented brother
i couldn't say talented for my cats i
had to use that for my brother otherwise
he would be disappointed so today i
actually want to talk about a very very
nice chapter of the book
called don't chase pawns too early i do
have a very very fun audience here
slightly higher than my rating it's
hurtful
i got uh chesweep here bonzo chest here
if are there any other streamers please
do let me know so i can announce i got
tracy here i don't know if tracy has a
personal stream all right so i'm very
excited about this i want to keep going
on this and
um
all right
let's jump to it
the first game that i want to show you
is from baby judith pogar she wasn't
exactly baby when she played this but it
was interesting because her rating was
like 23 something so that's for me
seeing judith pogar 2300 i'm just like
whoa
that that was a that was something i did
not expect
um yeah the audience can't see your
chats i don't know if they'll
i don't think they're gonna join the
camera so but they will see your chat
because we do have a live class here as
well
and
uh the two games that i'm gonna show you
are not that long
so
this will be rather fun
this was one of
the most brilliant games that i saw
uh of course is judith so most of our
games are going to be awesome
but
uh
she was uh she was 12 years old and
it was very interesting
so i'm gonna i'm gonna get started
let's go ahead see this beautiful game i
have tried this opening personally but i
usually did it more when there was d6
rather than knight c6 personal choice
but um
i would
i wouldn't give any recommendation on
the opening based on this game because
this is
a rather old game but
it's a very very beautiful one so
oh i see some persian there's a i see
salam i see some farsi oh i
remember
um jose angeli from when i lived in iran
but it's been a while
some of the guy that i remember was
really tiny and
so i think he's probably grown by now
anyways um it was a very this is a very
very beautiful game so i want to ask you
a very basic question and my mortal
enemy this mouse is still here this
mouse keeps making it keep making me
slip and show moves so i have to be very
careful with this guy he's very um
this one does it work okay
i'm trying but uh the problem is the um
it slips a lot and it shows moves
and all right i'll get another one thank
you
anyways so my first question for you all
and
for those of you who are not reading it
here what do you think white is
preparing to do why do you think the c3
is here just
we still have to
make sure we're keeping it
logical why do you play c3 you could
have done knight c3
alright alright the chat is answering
nice
oh i got the fake morris here
yeah
yeah exactly
thank you chad people
yeah we want to go for d4
uh so black tried to stop it by playing
e5 which is um
i would say dubious i i just like i'm
not a biggest fan when this squares gets
all weak
it's such a
such a
always going to be there it's ah it's
such a like a
was i was going to say immortal but i
realized that's not the word i'm looking
for
internal there we go internal weakness
and then the night if the knight can get
there this is just really uncomfortable
and unless you're planning on doing d5
relatively fast after that i'm not
really
buying this move uh oh see that's what
i'm talking about with the mouse knight
f6 would be interesting but then you
could simply continue
and then you would make simple moves you
could consider e5 and this is this is a
this is normal game there's nothing
wrong with it nobody's super winning
super losing this is just
fine
all right let's pray that this
will go back there we go
so e5 and judith went for d4
um now what do you think of course since
it's juted and i already said this is a
very beautiful game
and i think that kind of gives up the
moves that we're going to look at but
what do you think how do you feel about
d4
d4
it's kind of challenging are you gonna
take it are you gonna let it sit what
are you gonna think
what do you think we should do
you mean black
yes
should black be taking that should black
just play
a6 d6 whatever what do you think
rather take upon and then suffer that's
the mentality thank you
you're you you did right you came to my
class hungry didn't you
that's a that's the advice i've been
giving my students
because i um my schedule blew up and i
ended up with like a few dozen students
and um so i've been telling everybody
make sure you join my class hungry so we
can find the good eating moves anyways
yeah so that is true you got to take and
then let's take boom boom
and i was kind of thinking maybe bishop
d4 instead of pawn takes d4 what do you
guys think bishop d4
um
the bishop in the center
is that comfortable for black
because if there's no real you know
trouble with it
and
my in-person people don't look at that
side of the board just focus on
or take your glasses off now
corey
i don't know i don't think that's true
but i don't know you so
i don't think there's
there's always room for improvement for
everybody
all right
um
all right
nobody wants to do anything as white
is b4 here a problem i like my rooks
so i would say yes
attacking a c pawn
indirectly i can live with that
so how are we feeling
how much do we like that bishop on d4
should we attack it should we just
ignore it
i see some knight c3 aka ignorance or
rookie one which is again ignoring it
develop the knight
yeah i guess
i like that
um i prefer bishop tree
my reasoning is if you were to take it
oh yay mouse and t
ben simon's the rescue thank you
and then we could take that
and black is upon up but
how do you actually plan to develop your
pieces what do you plan to do knight f6
sure i can even do
even e5 and queen d6 and so many things
if knight e7 sure
i still have a relatively pleasant
position where does this go hold on
ah there it is
so i'm gonna be working with two mouse
instead of one
all right let me disable this one
there we go
bye bye mouse
okay
uh this this is this is fine for white
um i think with bishop e3 the only thing
that you would have to kind of make sure
that we're comfortable with is bishop b2
even though you see a nice question mark
here
you will be losing your rook so it's
important to be comfortable with that
sacrifice
so bishop b2 you get knight d2 develop
take take and there's a nice route for
the knight as well
and now
this is also under attack
so let's say opponent tries to defend it
again you are going to continue
um that's considered rook d1 but bishop
f4 is also same same thing you're gonna
this is this is just too good to be true
all your pieces are super active
um i'm even thinking if we can throw in
a rookie one e5 at some point this is
this is just too good this is i don't
think anybody is going to argue with
this
if you are leave a comment i'll argue
back with you
um yeah
i don't think bishop is something to be
worried about and rightfully so bishop
d4 because of bishop e3 gets a little
uncomfortable because then you would
have to take take and there are a lot of
developmental issues so
um opponents took the pawn and i want
you guys to think here
as if you have the book you'll probably
see there is a position there
um what do you think white should do
12 year old judith polgar
we already know she won the game i
already kind of gave that spoiler
what do you think
judith did
so why to move
enjoy
that's a very logical one not opposed to
it
but keep looking
so let's say
if what if bishop takes
okay then you're pinning it and then f4
is coming up so that's fine so e5 what
if knight goes to e7
so para i'm not opposed to attacking the
king because black is underdeveloped but
we got to find the right way of doing it
so i see a 98 in the chat i see a queen
a4 i see a knight d2 i see bishop f4 all
these moves are logical because your
opponent is on
well rather i was going to say
underdeveloped but i'm not going to
change it to undeveloped because i don't
there's just one bishop that's out there
so
we um
we can't we do have the luxury of
enjoying this game a little bit but
as chess bonzo correctly said
i think e5
yep e5 is the way to go the idea is that
now there's no more knight of six the
bishop is caught so this will be mine
and um there's no e there's no fun d6 e
there's no ideas here if i can
this is a very beautiful outpost if i
can get this night there that'll be
i think the end of it
uh so opponents went ahead and she
played knight e7 now what do we do
to be fair we can eat the pawn
but think about
strongest moves not just okay moves
how do you think we can best use
the fact that
black is okay now black is
underdeveloped there we go now it makes
sense
i like it
why
what if they just castle
um
i just felt like you're being annoying
well there we go finally i say this
almost every time we're up here
that
when i initially wanted to teach this
class
the first thing that came to my mind as
a name was how to play chess annoyingly
but that wasn't really user friendly
so the club managers were like we're not
opposed to the idea we like the content
but maybe a more um you know
friendly name so we ended up with chess
and psychology but the content is how to
annoy the opponent
so you're in the right place if you're
here for that
uh yeah bishop g5 is actually there
finally i think after a year you're
there
i think i need a new title to give to my
students annoying master
all right no i like bishop d4 uh bishop
g5 queen tanks d4 is fine there's
nothing absolutely nothing wrong with it
black can't play knight c6 you're going
to do queen d6 this is still this is
still
relatively comfortable for white i don't
think anybody is going to object to that
however
why should i make my opponent happy with
giving them a small knight c6 to attack
my claim when i can play bishop g5 and
stare into their eyes bishop g5 there
you go
and now if bishop e5 then what do we do
ah here's our friend
beautiful bishop
you can you can also do rookie one after
wait i actually don't know who to look
at
oh hi sorry it's so dark well so light
here and they're so dark there
so yeah i like the idea of rookie one
but
to stop castle i think bishop h6 what if
opponent goes like knight five
i wouldn't move that bishop
if it wasn't with temple
ah i think pera is thinking about it's
para
phoenix
i guess
i'm not opposed to rookie one but this
is just ah this is just stronger
take
go straight for it and just because if
the bishop moves then you got rookie one
right and if queen tries to go boom you
win the piece
if the king takes it haha well i don't
know if i should really talk about this
so i'm just gonna
gently show this
and boom there we go i think that's good
enough for now there was another thing
so rookie one
as how i'm not opposed to it i also
don't necessarily love it because you
know
uh people tend to find weird
weirdly good moves under pressure so
this is when people would find weirdly
good moves under pressure and then it
just you would have to move the bishop
again and then they can try to notify it
they can just king of it's just too much
hassle to deal with just
don't even go there if um
if rookie one gives opponents a tempo
don't don't even don't even go for it
all right so
bishop g5 keep the mentality of annoying
your opponent
now castle now what do we do anything to
eat anything to pressure
scott um one thing that i've realized is
that i sometimes i don't have enough
words to describe what i want to
describe so just come up with words and
people don't understand so
yeah
i just don't like that
well they eat it
i would there you go
i'm glad we agree on that there you go
yeah knight c6 they want to exchange
queens we don't want to exchange queens
because
okay there's so many reasons which one
should i choose let's go with the with
the my pieces are under attack i think
that's a good start and there's this too
and then the other part of it is that
you have a dynamic advantage if you had
like an extra rook and your opponents
proposed a queen exchange i would be
like yeah why not i have an extra rook i
don't need to attack i can just enjoy my
opponents you'll they'll be annoyed
enough with the list hook
um
but the problem is that because i don't
really have that um
that stable advantage i just have better
peace activity better space
okay to be fair i do have a nice square
but
i don't want i don't want to bother
myself with having to deal with
lack of queens i'm just going to
continue with my attack exactly
and
even if like even if 28 worked and i
wasn't losing a piece i wouldn't still
do it even if bishop did to exchange the
queens all right opponent and queen b6
this is a simple move knight b3
just simply defending the bishop your
knight is getting developed
you might want to consider some stuff
like that but again keep in mind that
the bishop could fall
so
let's see in the game black played
bishop takes e5 what do you think
greedy
or good
well there's a question mark
ah well that that
that gives it away
i agree it is quite sad set of
development for black i would say it's
questionable
all right
that's a good good answer it is even
leeches is questioning your tongue
so what do you think white should do
and or you can tell me what do you think
black should have done instead of bishop
bishop takes e5
knight e4 with 10 point thread to go
into f6 whoa i think i'm in knight d5
but if knight d5 queen takes
my bishop
yeah i like rookie one simple moves all
right we'll come back to this in a
second let's say what do you think is
actually a good move for black
so we just played knight c3
black to move
black has that
very unfortunate bishop stuck
behind palms
people are talking about to get your
work involved with the game you got to
get your bishop uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh i can't let him sit back there i
like that logic so what's the move
when you gotta put your
black needs to put his
work
yes
i'll give you a small um
i guess well you kind of mentioned it
but i'll give you a small hint anyways
because the knight is kind of
preoccupied defending this bishop and
this bishop kind of has half an eye on
this knight
the move d5 makes it the move d5 makes a
lot of sense
because you can't unplus on it because
well
this will be uncomfortable
right and
black is already capable of um
picturing a future in this game i don't
like that i want hopeless opponents i
mean i want happy opponents just not
over the board
i hope no kids are watching this
i can't teach ethics over
that
number that's a brutal game exactly but
i i i teach a lot of young children and
i don't want to
you know tell them like go torture your
opponents i don't wanna i don't wanna
say
stuff like that so i i'll settle for
annoy
but yeah so like right now you you you
don't have enough pieces to annoy
the opponent
so
uh there's a question why not d6 well
let's go back
uh d5 is
i'm more comfortable with d5 because
knight can't take this falls right
uh d6 i see what you're attacking but
a part of me just wants to take it over
here and be done with it
another part of me wants bishop f6
what else do i want
i'm kind of happy with this though take
i can take you can you take i'll just do
this easy peasy
take here i'll take that i'm i'm not
gonna complain about having a beautiful
bishop
yeah i i don't know d5
makes more sense because you're you're
not you're also kind of making the
opponent question hmm should i do the
ampersand whereas d6 is more of an offer
oh there you go there's a psychology
behind it
yeah i to me d5 makes better sense than
d6 but if you come up with a better
answer than i gave please leave it in
the chat or comment below
we would like to hear from you
so opponent that bishop e5 which we said
uh-uh two and then we talked about
rookie one and then we talked about well
actually that's where we stopped now
what do you think is the best move for
black
black's bishop is problematic because if
it's white to move right now white does
want to eat on the um
c6 knight and pick up the e5 bishop so
bishop g7 is natural
is it
i see a bishop takes c3 bishop g7 queen
c5 oh boy queen c5
i don't think capture the knight is
pretty
for black right uh it's doable but is it
good
multi we'll come back to that in a
second queen have c5 the first problem i
see with this is what if i'll just do
bishop takes c6
because if pawn takes i have bishop e7
and i'm doing a beautiful fork to your
queen and rook
if bishop takes c6 if queen takes your
bishop drops if um because queen c5
wasn't ah that would be nice if queen c5
take this is also a possibility
but i'm just thinking about
enjoying this
i don't see any problems with this
you might be able to find better moves
but i'm if this is the position i'm
perfectly happy
so
okay
we talked about oh bishop g7 yeah bishop
g7 possible we can just go for bishop c4
enjoy this
uh if you eat my pawn my night is free
and i'll just do this
and you can't really
escape that
the other thing that was i don't think
anybody actually mentioned that was f6
uh d6
um
that idea of visualistic still exists
so you have to
just be mindful of that if you're fine
with that
good for you but i'm not comfortable
with that with bishop f6 existing
anyways uh f6 would be the best one and
after f6 white uh probably have to do
like bishop h6 jerk moves check
and there's rookie six now
why tim what do you think we should do
we could take the rook but
do we have anything
better
always sack this change exchange i'm not
opposed to it let's go
take boom
beautiful checkmate coming up
i'll wait
oh
got it nice nice
glad you like it all right very nice
so
um
bishop takes c3
what do you think should we take back or
do we have some super cool magical moves
too many gifts
a little
so
do we have a verdict are we just going
to take that back
or
any bishop moves any
weird cool rook moves
are we just going to go
vanilla and just take the bishop
i think i
made everybody
confused
i see a lot of doubts and
audiences eyes i love it
i think half of my job is to make you
doubt the whole chest
oh god
all right
let's just take it
let's just
just
just go for just take it slow just take
the bishop one step at a time
they'll take your bishop then what do
you do
like to play bishop f6
right it wasn't possible if we didn't
take that right hold on no if bishop f6
what is your opponent going to do yeah
and it's funny we have a very very
beautiful
checkmate there
but that's not the only thing that's
coming up
what if opponent plays queen f5 now
they're stopping bishop f6 right
so
you could do a record
tejona
what happens to always scan for checks
ouch
i'll give you all a minute
whoa anonymous i think
you got to take a deep breath buddy
why is it that people are just loving g4
opponent will take with check
queen queen takes
king takes
there you go
yep
beautiful checkmate ah they resigned
this is hurtful
anyways um this is a very very very
beautiful game
and
yeah unfortunately black resign i i hate
it on opponents to that like if i've
already gotten this beautiful checkmate
at least grant me the pleasure of doing
it
right yeah because the then they'll they
would have to take and ah come back boom
boom
right beautiful wow
yeah so it was interesting because
let's circle back to the
chapter title of don't chase pawns too
early this was when your opponent went
um
black she started to chase pawns way too
early
basically opponents she was a very
experienced one grandmaster she went to
just chase pawns and grab ponds and she
lost in 17 moves to a 12 year old
although she did become the strongest
top 10 in the world and like strongest
woman in the world now you know all
those but still 12 year olds
so yeah i guess the moral story of that
not every pawn is good to
chase
especially at the beginning of the game
and we're going to look at another game
that is not as short but
yeah
all right
let me scroll down
yeah this one was played by white was uh
parham masoodle
who
i
i grew up knowing and i mean we haven't
really talked in years but um he's i
think he recently did become a super
grandmaster right
okay that was a knock thank you
i i keep losing track of my weeks so
just
right now i feel like i'm still back in
july so
anyways i'm just gonna go ahead and get
started and we'll talk about the game as
we go
um
this is another and another very
interesting game because black
was like 200 rating points actually
exactly
200 rating points less than white and it
was very interesting because um i
believe black was the younger opponent
in this case
and
yeah and power home was the more
experienced stronger uh he had the all
the advantages in that case but he uh
probably under mister underestimated his
14 year old opponent and just went for
pawns and he got punished and we're
gonna watch that
all right so
i'm just gonna kind of uh go through the
opening a little faster
let's just keep going i actually used to
play this bishop v7 when i played um
queen scan but declined more often i
like bishop e7 more than knight f6 just
has that little extra
thing to it to makes the opponent think
some people pre-move bishop g5 so yo
you're gonna enjoy that huh all right so
crossbar pawn structure let's keep going
all right
uh let's see parham started to
hunt pawns
so like to move do we care
okay how's the chat doing okay chad's
thinking knight c6 double dare
wait how's 96 a double door oh if queen
takes b7 okay
cold blooded knight c6 queen gets
trapped
hmm
okay somebody cares about the b7 pawn
well buddy
this chapter is for you
castle
um
okay we have a certain degree of not
caring
even if i don't want to care i still
want to care about development i'm not
saying castling is a bad idea
but
might be uh
you might want to consider developing
your knight before that because if you
don't then queen takes p7 will be
attacking your rook
all right yeah but then the d5 pawn is
weak the c7 policy there's just way too
many okay
wobbly stuff
d7 first i'm gonna go with knight c6
yeah
if you take it no i'm just gonna
join forces on this week's square
oh i see a knight a5 first um
knight a5 what would you do after queen
b5 for example you'd have to play pawn
to c6
then the queen can just go back
somewhere i'm just going to put it here
your knight is a little weird on a5
knight tonight b4 makes more sense
i actually have a serious threat for you
you got to play rook c1 it is possible
to do bishop b5 but we can simply ignore
it
this would be a little bit better for
white but you can do like a tiny fake
tiny fake castle
um so opponents
power hunt pointer at c1
and black just castled now why not c2 is
not a good idea
as you see there's a question
why would it be a good idea
do you tell me it's a cheque
anonymous we did we did kind of mention
if bishop b5 when we just said king f8
and we would just want to go g6k g7 so
we're just gonna chill
um well if king d2 was the answer we
would be happy
so
exactly bishop takes boom you got to
move the queen another check you got to
move it another temple
white would just go
attack attack attack attack
all right
let's go back so let's say not knight c2
let's just do the logical castling queen
takes c7
kind of gotta exchange it so we're not
trying to trap the queen that's not the
idea here
the idea is to use our
piece activity
opponent is two pawns up
but black is totally fine
all right um
black gotta be fast though i think
that's the only thing that you have to
consider you can't just play like a slow
rookie eight slow knight d7 you gotta
you gotta you gotta be chopped up fast
all right so rookie of eight if bishop
went to g3 this knight e4 is kind of
cool too
because you're going after that bishop
and this knight is pinned right
so
what if bishop goes to f4 then what do
you do should we still go for the same
knight d4 idea
g6 why
mine takes a2 whoa whoa whoa night takes
a two
take take take your time
i think i lost on somebody went back to
sleep
all right 94 yes let's go for it
and now
f3 this must be
i think this was a point that i started
to question at the game
g4 seems to be a little
more
um
played by other people
so g4 take take then take
and this is you just give those two
pawns back and
this is fine why just spends time
developing and
nobody is better nobody is worse this is
just
okay position very playable
so the fact that um white i think white
was a little greedy and didn't want to
give these pawns back okay there's like
a a3 but after a3
we could it's also funny we can do a5 if
you take i take this knight is having
problems if you go a2
wait i can just take that why did i
suggest that
if you go the other way i can just take
her k1 and this is just so
beautiful
right this is just super winning for
black the other thing that we could
possibly consider was
there's a bishop b5 and there's g5 and
this gets really complicated
so
possible too
but what i thought would be interesting
to mention
was
this f3 that was played
was relatively a new move
so
do you think it's a good move or bad
move
and what should black do
yeah yeah what do you think black should
do now
um
fair point
okay
i agree let's take if the rook takes we
just we would just take that attack the
rook rook takes takes and just this is
just too too pretty
and if the pawn takes we're gonna
do this
g5 was
something that i
didn't necessarily want to consider at
first i was just thinking about knight
takes a2
but knight takes a2 you might be giving
your opponent a little bit of leeway
and white's still giving up those extra
pawns
um but white is gaining space so
that's on a maybe pile for me
um so g5 was something that i
didn't
feel that instant connection to
um
knight c2 was another thing that i
briefly considered but i immediately
just was like oh boy now g5 is fine
um
and after g5 bishop went away and then
black flied a5
so
i black has to wait too much patience i
would have eaten this like five times
already
so
yeah
yeah this is this is relatively
interesting because you're truly like
knowing your opponent like at some point
i think
one of the things that would white would
be quite bothered but it's like are you
gonna finally eat that pond like truly
if you're not gonna eat it then i'm
gonna move it like that question of like
when is they gonna when are they gonna
eat it
are they ever gonna eat it that's just
like that that suspends i guess
that tension is rather uncomfortable
so
um
bishop g3 a5
and a4 was finally played so white made
a decision that i'm going to save my
pawn
interestingly enough if a3 was played
they would do knight a2
they would eat this
and then we would push over here
again this is relatively comfortable
uh because we are still attacking a
bunch of stuff
we still have very very pretty
developments and i don't really see how
white can
have much of a compensation
so
sorry powerhome
and uh so that's why atria actually
wasn't played so i guess that's good a4
knight a2 move it boom we're gonna take
now um
ignites e2 you gotta develop somehow so
what do you think we should do as black
develop that bishop exactly great job
simple moves
king went to f2 now what did we do
the trading night says favorable for
white so don't do it
i i'm not opposed to that para thanks
oh somebody in the chat
mentioning bishop again while bishop
where i need more
knight takes knight bishop texture c2 is
an option
it is an option but do you have anything
better
better
pin the bishop after takes whoa
so many people want to take that knight
what do you have against that knight
there you go bishop c2 thank you bishops
it is actually relatively interesting
take take
and here parham played jerky too what do
you okay actually i was gonna say how do
you feel about it but this gives it away
unfortunately
how do i stop that
no
because annotations on board
oh thank you
oh yeah that actually helps
all right thank you
so what do we think
rookie 2 or rook a3
what's wrong with texting knight and
roxy too um you're helping your opponent
develop rook c2 then an opponent can
simply just develop the rook
okay three is a blunder how come
okay you're saying rook a3 then there
would be bishop b2
um yes and no because after bishop b2
there is rookie two
so if for extra k3 would make a lot of
sense because then
if there's rk1 all right well that'll be
it actually
yeah so
it's very like a
high high
type of feeling but
this 3k3 was the only
move that had the potential of saving
the game because
well
what do you what can white what can
black do here if it's white temple was
just gonna develop if you give white two
moves then white is the one
um
asking for a win
so well i want to say a win advantage
asking for comfort let's go with that
yeah
and the white has an extra pawn so it
does have the luxury of time
so
rook a3 would have been very interesting
um
white played rk2
now what do we do
we got few ideas
does bishop e4 work
i don't want to give up free stuff
if the rakana it was active black would
be crushing i'm not yeah i mean if that
rook was on like b1
yeah
move rook
wait a second what is your opponent
attacking
there's a bishop b1 okay i see there's a
lot of bishop b1 suggestion coming up
yeah
and the rookie one rookie two was just
the last of it
instead of rookie two uh instead of
rookie two
rook a3 would again make sense if up
here then all right bishop v2
wait a second
take
take
up there
double up
whoops sorry possible but i mean black
is not black has definitely
advantage but still not as comfortable
as what happened in the game so um still
keep in mind that we shouldn't make our
opponents super comfortable we should
still make them work for it
and so
rock b3 was another idea
instead of bishop b1
oh this should be 3 or k3
and then i wanted to put it on c4
wouldn't mind if they exchanged
oh well sorry
it's okay
it's too dark i can't even see who's
talking tracy was that you
all right arcade 2 bushel b1
arcade 2
or c4
beautiful
a lot of stuff to eat
now if i entered rook c2 i'm i'm just
not sure if i like this
yeah if take take i think the only trick
is like there's this rook c1
if take they take this
bishop b3 and they'll be able to hold
the draw
but i don't well like i don't i'm not
obligated today to take that to date
that truck that tooth
but still i don't have to do anything to
this drug
i can just let it be
right
so ah no
okay uh
that mouse that was actually me not the
mouse sorry
um why uh
black to move what do we do and don't
forget what's the first thing we should
always think of thank you
and where is your check
there you go
take and boom
and okay this is just winning double up
the rocks
enjoy this
and
that should be the end of it
yeah
so perham just resigned and
it was a very very interesting game
that's black played with 200 points less
much younger
and
again
don't
eat material when not ready i think
there's also a chapter
we we changed out the names a lot but
there is a chapter in the book
that is actually encouraging eating
and um we actually at the end of it we
do have a fun little
um
recipe thing i won't tell much about it
you got to get it to see it
but
like there's a chapter that's literally
telling you grab it while you can eat it
the other one right now this one is
don't chase pawns too early so
we are showing you both sides of it
and when to eat when not to eat
but
it is a very very
there's also something about wine turn
water into wine
i actually don't like wine
however i like a very specific wine
i got spoiled because i found the
perfect wine
anyways uh anyway so
i'm gonna let that sit i'm gonna
show my book baby one more time
oops hold on
and my beautiful fur baby and my baby
brother
oh my god this is weird and so yes
please
feel free to
get it
let me know how you like it
it's like 400 pages so you'll have a lot
to go over
and for those of you who will be staying
around we will do a switch to twitch and
we will be analyzing your games
so
please
do have games ready join us on leeches i
want to say about 10 minutes no no more
i think 10 minutes a good
point and um
yeah join us there for
a fun analyze your game
and if not i'll see you guys next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you